so despite the Adventist Church's
defense to this being that she was
differentiating between the father and
the son here this evidence is that the
Adventist Church's understanding of the
Trinity and Christ's nature are
significantly warped and outright
[Music]
what's up YouTube as always welcome to
the channel we're continuing our series
and examining the Jesus of adventism up
and against the Jesus of history and
scripture if you missed part one I
suggest checking that out first the link
to that is in the description box down
below last time we looked a little bit
at what the Adventist Church calls the
great controversy and how the exaltation
of Jesus to be made equal with the
father supposedly caused Lucifer to
become jealous and rebel today I want to
look at something equally as aberrant
that Ellen White said regarding the
nature of Christ but first I want to
establish something from the scriptures
regarding Christ nature if you recall
last time we looked at Isaiah and
Colossians showing that Jesus is the one
Lord Yahweh who created all things this
is not to the exclusion of the father
and the Holy Spirit but demonstrates his
equality within the godhead something
that has always been and always will be
I want to further bolster this claim by
taking a look at Mark 1 where it reads
the beginning of the Gospel of Jesus
Christ the son of God as it is written
in Isaiah the prophet behold I send my
messenger before your face who will
prepare your way the voice of one crying
in the wilderness prepare the way of the
Lord make his path straight
so at the start of his gospel Mark
mentions and quotes Isaiah who
prophesied that there would be a
messenger crying in the wilderness which
was talking about John the Baptist he
says that John would Herald prepare the
way of the Lord John of course was
speaking of Jesus Christ well if we go
back to Isaiah 40 where Mark is quoting
from we read this
a voice cries in the wilderness prepare
the way of the Lord make straight in the
desert a highway for our God
Isaiah prophesied about God Almighty the
Lord Yahweh who would have his way
prepared for him by a predecessor who
was John the Baptist thus demonstrating
that Jesus Christ is the Lord God
Almighty In the Flesh in Revelation 15
3-4 we see the same thing the multitude
of saints in heaven singing the song of
the lamb say this
and they sing the song of Moses the
servant of God and the song of the lamb
saying great and amazing are your Deeds
O Lord God the almighty just and true
are your ways O King of the Nations who
will not fear O Lord and Glory your name
for you alone Are Holy All Nations will
come and worship you for your righteous
acts have been revealed
and then a mere 11 verses later the
Saints under the altar that were
mentioned back in Revelation 6 9 singing
to the Lord Jesus say this
yes Lord God the almighty true and just
are your judgments
so very clearly Jesus Christ is the Lord
God Almighty with that established let's
take a look at a quote from the SDA
prophetess Ellen G white and I want you
to remember she claimed to never write
one sentence of heresy and lift him up
on page 235 she writes the following
there is no one who can explain the
mystery of the Incarnation of Christ yet
we know that he came to this earth and
lived as a man among men the man Christ
Jesus was not the Lord God Almighty yet
Christ and the father are one the deity
did not sink under the agonizing torture
of Calvary yet it is nonetheless true
that God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son that whosoever
believeth in him should not perish but
have everlasting life
so despite the Adventist Church's
defense to this being that she was
differentiating between the father and
the son here this evidence is that the
Adventist Church's understanding of the
Trinity and Christ's nature are
significantly warped and outright
heretical the phrase almighty God is not
a valid differentiator between the
father and the son as Father Son and
Holy Spirit are all the single almighty
God yet again we see that the Jesus of
adventism is a different Christ that
both Jesus and Paul warned about if you
found today's video helpful make sure to
smash that like button subscribe and
ring the notification Bell so you can be
notified when content like this is
uploaded as always I'll catch you guys
around next time God bless
[Music]
thank you